alright hello everybody happy National
Pancake Day by the way I don't know if
you can hear it but I'm coming down with
a little bit of a thing a little bit of
a sickness and so I'm gonna try to get
through this best I can actually my
whole family's been sick for the last
for the last like week and I thought
that I had escaped I was feeling pretty
proud of myself I was feeling proud of
my immune system and so I was saying to
my immune system way to go I'm proud of
you and then it immediately just let me
down you know there's there's there's
nothing worse by the way than being the
last person in the family to get sick
nothing worse than that because for one
thing you're left out I mean you're left
out to begin with because everybody's
sick at the same time and they're
hanging out and they're bonding and
they're having their popsicles in their
soup and they're having sick people
conversations and you're the odd man out
but then it flips around and they're all
healthy and they've in all the soup and
all the popsicles are gone and nobody
wants to bond anymore they're all
staying away from me because they don't
I get the sickness again and the other
problem is that there's the comparison
that they'll make so everyone's rawls
comparison so they'll say oh you're
still sick after three days well I was
fine after two trying to make you feel
like a wimp or they'll go in the other
direction and they'll say oh you only
have a fever of 100 well I had a fever
of 115 and so I don't know maybe which
is probably a total exaggeration by the
way anyway I want to I want to take a
break from the from the cabin all circus
to talk about a different circus this
one down in Texas there's an interesting
case involving the pledge of allegiance
and let me read the report from the
Washington Times for you
it says Texas state officials have
intervened in a dispute over the Pledge
of Allegiance backing a local school
districts expulsion of a student who sat
during it according to a report in the
Houston Chronicle Attorney General Ken
Paxton filed a notice to intervene in a
civil rights lawsuit brought against
Cypress Fairbanks ISD arguing that
skooch school children cannot
unilaterally refuse to participate in
the pledge students India Landry was
expelled from Winfred High School last
fall for refusing to participate in the
pledge saying she's been inspired by the
NFL players such as Colin Kaepernick
with the support of her parents miss
Landry who was black then sued the Sipho
ISD saying the expulsion violated her
free speech rights and was racially
motivated
the Attorney General's filing cites
Supreme Court finding that government
can back quote the national flag as a
symbol of our country Texas law allows
parents to submit a letter claiming an
exemption from standing for the pledge
but it apparently was not filed by Miss
Landry's parents the Texas law says
standing for the pledge is mandatory
otherwise and so okay that's the story
so I have a few different points several
opinions here and I'm all over the map
so I'm sure that I'll alienate everyone
that's my goal here is I'm gonna alien
alienate everyone and by the end of this
both sides will disagree with me and
that's because that's where I feel most
comfortable is where everybody is mad at
me so first of all and I know that I
will not find many conservative people
who will agree with me on this point but
I am NOT a fan really of the Pledge of
Allegiance in public school I the thing
itself is fine but the mandatory pledge
of allegience oh I'm not a fan of that I
don't like it for two reasons one I'm
not sure I see the point in forcing kids
to stand and pledge allegiance to their
country it seems to be a bit of an empty
ritual to me I mean this thing as a
ritual doesn't make sense to me now if
you can show me that it increases
patriotism and moneta really sink in and
help kids be loyal and patriotic
citizens then maybe I'll change my mind
but I don't think it has that effect I
don't I don't think you can show me that
I don't think that I don't think that
that's really they've been the trend of
things in fact it seems like patriotism
has been sort of plummeting even though
kids are forced to say the Pledge I'm
not saying that saying the pledge causes
the patriotism to plump plummet but what
I am saying is I don't think there's any
evidence that forcing kids to say the
Pledge is likely to instill patriotism
in them I think it has no effect one way
or another and by definition a pledge of
loyalty and fidelity that you're forced
to say a pledge of appreciation for
freedom which you are compelled to say
seems rather counterintuitive because
when you say
a kid stand and pledge your loyalty or
you'll be expelled it seems unlikely
that the pledge will then mean anything
because then they're just doing what
they have to do they're doing what
they're told Vaz and pledges which are
compelled are not really there for vows
or pledges they are just words that you
are forced to say and so you said them
too
I don't like the pledge of allegiance
because it says one nation indivisible
now the under got one nation under God
the under God part I like indivisible I
don't like I don't like now I don't mean
to get into semantics but the nation is
not actually indivisible I believe that
states have the right or ought to have
the right to secede if they like because
the state of California for instance
where they want to secede well
California is not owned by the federal
government okay
the federal government doesn't own
California doesn't own the people of
California doesn't own California itself
California entered into the Union by
choice it should have the choice to
leave if it wants to I kind of hope it
does but that's beside the point
so indivisible to me I just don't like
in fact the pledge of allegiance was was
originally written a lot of people don't
know this the Pledge of Allegiance was
written by a guy named Francis Bellamy
who was a socialist okay so that this
was this was a socialist idea to have
everybody getting up and forced to say
you know the Pledge one nation
indivisible this was a socialist idea to
begin with and I think you can kind of
see why so that's my feeling on the
pledge but second this is where I start
to win back maybe some conservatives who
knows here's my second point even though
I'm not a big fan of the pledge at
school I think that kids ought to stand
for it although I don't necessarily
think the pledge accomplishes anything I
think as long as it's being recited kids
should stand for it now as an adult
who's not in public school I have the
right to you know I can make my own
decisions about the pledge I can do what
I want but children ends
should be required to obey you know
that's my main issue with kids who don't
stand for the pledge it's not that
they're being unpatriotic because as I
said forced expressions of patriotism
are not really patriotism but the issue
to me is that they're being disobedient
and that they're calling attention to
themselves and they're refusing to
respect the authority of the people who
are in charge of them at school that to
me is the issue it is disobedience so we
have somewhere along the line we've
completely lost sight of this idea of
obedience and respect for your elders
and listen I know that since time
immemorial adults have been complaining
that kids don't respect their elders and
don't listen but now we seem to have
categorically kind of rejected given up
on the very idea of kids being required
to obey and this has a lot to do with
parents so you have parents who send
their kids to school and the kid is
disobedient disrespectful defiant and
then the parents find out about it and
they side with their kid against the
adults these parents they want to have
it both ways they want the school system
to babysit their kids but they don't
want the school system to have any
authority over their kids you can't do
that if you're putting your kid under
the authority of the school system then
the kid must be required to respect that
authority and you if you're a good
parent should should tell your kid that
my kids you know they know that when
they're being watched by a babysitter or
if they're going to Nana and Grandpa's
house or if they're ever in the custody
of some adult who is not mommy or daddy
they know because we tell them that
those adults now have the authority of
mommy and daddy and they are to listen
and they are to obey and if the
babysitter tells us that the kids were
being disrespectful we're not going to
take the kid's side you know in fact my
wife and I came home from a date night a
few weeks ago and the babysitter told us
that our daughter screamed at her and
stomped out of the room for some reason
or another and so I went upstairs and my
daughter was already in bed and I got
her out of bed and I marched downstairs
and I made her
guys to the babysitter I didn't take her
side
I didn't say well honey why did you
stomp out of the room and scream at the
OSHA was mean to you well then it's okay
I'm gonna make her apologize to you no I
didn't do that because I'm not a
horrible parent i entrusted my child
into the care of this babysitter and so
now it's my responsibility to back up
the babysitter and to take her side and
that's how it should be with school too
when I went to public school my parents
were very clear that I was to listen to
my teacher do as I was told be
respectful and now I didn't always
fulfill that obligation okay III but
when I failed to fulfill it which
frankly was pretty often my parents
almost always took the teachers side
against me and rightly so this student
from what I read disobeyed her teachers
refused to stand some two hundred times
okay this was consistent defiance of the
people who were in charge of her and no
she does not have a right to defy them
she has to do what she's told because
she's a kid and she's at school and
they're in charge of her and that's what
her parents should be telling her they
should be telling her oh you have you
okay you don't like the pledge that's in
you know we could talk about that you
have interesting ideas about them that's
fine but when you're at school you do
what you're told
um third point people say this is a free
speech thing kids have free speech in
school well no they don't
actually public this idea that kids are
free you just have blanket free speech
in school is so stupid
it-it's so crazy public schools are
government institutions you are sending
your kid to a government building
entrusting them into the care of
government employees you are handing
over your kids to whatever programs
whatever rules whatever systems this
government institution has in place
don't like it don't send them to public
school but if you send them there you
can't then go on about their freedoms
and their rights
they are children who you as the parent
have put under the authority of this
government institution so they do not
have the right to do whatever they want
say whatever they want and make whatever
statements they want they don't have
that right they don't have it now even
if they weren't in public school they
still wouldn't have the right to do and
say whatever they want children do not
have full free speech rights children
because they are not yet emancipated are
always under the authority of someone
whether it's a parent a teacher a
guardian a babysitter whatever
and those authority figures have the
right and the power to require the
children to do things and not do things
now obviously if those things if those
things that they're being required to do
are criminal or immoral then then
children you know have the right to
disobey but but barring that children
must obey my kids do not have free
speech in my house okay my house is not
a democracy
they don't have equal rights they don't
have free speech rights they don't have
First Amendment rights they don't have
second they don't have third they don't
have any of the amendment rights in my
house none of them I got news for you
because it's my house No and so and so
they have to listen my kids don't I have
free speech in my house my wife has free
speech our kids because they are our
kids and we're in charge of them and we
own the house and we own everything
because of that they're required to obey
so if my daughter calls my son a little
dumb boy which he did this morning but
my son came running upstairs because my
daughter had called him a little dumb
boy but and in fact she called him she
called him dumb this is like a thing she
could you know we're trying to break her
of this habit that she's getting in the
habit of calling him dumb and a few days
ago she called him dumb and and I and I
said to her why did you say that which
is a dumb question on my part it's just
like instinctive but I said why do you
why did you say that why
you call him dumb and she said because
he was acting dumb and I wanted to say
okay well alright fair enough but anyway
so she called my you know she called her
brother a little dumb boy and and and so
I you know we had to talk to her about
that she can't claim that it's her First
Amendment right to say that the First
Amendment is irrelevant she has no right
to say that to her brother you know what
you know why she has no right to say
that to her brother because we as the
parents have told her she's not allowed
to say that and so she does she gets
punished that's how it works with kids
so all these people that are fret you
know talking about free speech I mean do
you real is that how you parent do you
really parent according to the Bill of
Rights with your kids no kids have to
listen and obey because they're kids
they don't have all the same rights
because they don't have the same
responsibilities as an adult you're you
pay taxes you you know you you have the
ability to own things you have a job and
and also you can if you commit a crime
you can go to prison for the rest of
your life you know you're tried as an
adult so there are all these different
responsibilities and things that you
face as an adult and so there are
certain rights that come along with
those but as a child you have really no
legal responsibilities whatsoever you
own nothing you do nothing right you're
you're always under the authority of
someone you're all you're always under
the direct authority of someone and so
therefore you don't have all the same
rights this idea that kids can just go
to school and they can just say whatever
they want make whatever statements they
want do whatever they want that's chaos
if that if we actually if schools
actually operated that way well then
schools would not be able to operate we
may as well just get rid of the school
system and have no schools anymore
because it's just not possible for a
school to function that way kids must be
forced and compelled to listen and open
and as a parent again if you're a good
parent and you're sending your kid to
school you should be telling your kid
that now I know for me you know when I
was a kid if i disobeyed my parents I
got in big trouble
but if I disobeyed an adult who my
parents had entrusted me to if i
disobeyed them I got in even more
trouble for that because my parents saw
it as you know it's it's defiance and
it's also an embarrassment to them they
feel like they're being embarrassed by
my behavior and so I get even more
trouble I just don't understand these
parents who say well you're not my kids
parent you don't have any authority well
if you don't want them if you don't want
the teachers to have any authority over
your kid don't send them to school you
better keep them home and homeschool
them if you don't want any teachers to
have authority over your kid but if you
send them there and you're using the
school system as a babysitter well then
there are certain things that come along
with that and it means that your kid has
to listen so yeah you know what we we
can talk about the Pledge of Allegiance
I we have an academic conversation about
it we have an interesting conversation
and you know I we can express our
opinions about it but in school if this
is what the teacher tells you to do then
you should do it because it's not
immoral it's not even legal so you stand
and you listen and you obey so that's my
feeling about this I mean and then as
far as expelling a kid for not saying
the Pledge you know that to me seems
rather extreme I'm not a big fan of that
but then again if it's a rule and she's
not listening and she's had 200 chances
what are you supposed to do at a certain
point so all right
we'll leave it there but I'll be
interested to read some of your comments
because I think it's an interesting
conversation thanks for listening thanks
for watching Godspeed